are you here now are you where are you
living in Dubai you're oh you are oh
yeah I've been there a few years well on
and off cuz I spend time in Athens - and
Mykonos sounds rough where did you
access it cuz I hear a little bit of an
accent where do you think you picked it
I think it's because especially
actresses even I think when I'm around
certain dialects it changes each time
with panels even and it you just pick
things up along the way yeah and you've
lived there for several years so you
know and I do sometimes I hear like um a
little thicker
maybe when you're here and goes away a
little a little bit in New York or yeah
it all started to come back if people
always have given me trouble for going
to clubs so why don't I just open my own
boss [ __ ] how much drama we see but but
for me it's it's the cameras flip so I'm
I'm kind of depicting how much drama
hello little hell s and then but yeah
there's and it's least I mean they're in
Mykonos it's their first time in Iike
knows coming from America and so that in
itself and enough and they're on camera
now so everybody is different and I see
that and I I recognize that my brother
they came before we started shooting the
show but my brother Michael yes he's on
it and his wife oh and some of my good
friends how is your relationship now
with your family or is it good yeah
we're all good yeah we're all good
everybody's been for a while
so um close with my family I love them
and they love when I'm here and I love
when they come to see me
[Music]